es soll jedenfalls das ist meine
persönliche meinung
jeder arbeitnehmer der das möchte auch
die chance haben eine solche maske zu
tragen
das wird nicht von heute auf morgen
möglich sein das muss man auch wissen
denn wenn sie das beispiel südkorea auf
deutschland um längen dann würden wir
etwa für zwei monate
anderthalb milliarden masken benötigen
das ist sehr sehr viel und trotzdem ein
land wie deutschland kann das stimmen
das können wir uns vornehmen und deshalb
sage ich wir müssen das ziel haben in
den nächsten vier fünf sechs wochen die
produktion von masken so zu vergrößern
dass jeder bürger der eine haben möchte
auch eine bekommen kann